[Music]
tiffany's next in
austin texas hi tiffany how are you
hi mr ramsey i'm a new listener and um a
colleague has suggested that
i i call in today okay
um so recently i've been really focusing
on
paying off my debt with my husband and
this morning i was
um served papers from a student loan
that i thought was
no longer my responsibility um it was a
private student loan that i had gotten
out years ago with my
deceased grandfather i have
at the time we couldn't afford to pay it
back when my grandfather passed away
newly married and then i started
disputing it on
my credit report on both transunion and
equifax
and each time i disputed it it came back
that it was not
my debt and it has since come off
all of my credit reporting over the last
three to four years
um it did i did notice whenever i got
served this morning i went and checked
and it was
on my equifax report um
but i'm just not sure what to do with
this thing i've never been sued or
anything like that and that kind of
scares you doesn't it
yeah i'm a little bit emotional today so
i told my husband
i'm gonna call i don't want to cry and
my mom just passed away a few months ago
so i'm like i'm gonna cry
that's okay i'm sorry so how much is the
debt
um so the random thing is there's
actually two of them but they are only
sending it for one it's uh
twelve thousand nine hundred and thirty
dollars and eighty cents
okay well here's the equation
if you signed a contract
saying that you owe the debt when you
took it out
with your grandfather then you
are liable whether it's on your credit
bureau report or not
does not affect your legal liability
you can have something that is never on
your credit bureau report and you're
legally liable because you signed a
contract
saying you would pay it if however your
grandfather
signed it and you're listed as the
person who got the money for college but
you did not sign the agreement then you
are not
liable and you will need an attorney
so we don't know based on what you've
told me do you have any documents from
any of this yeah i'm looking at it it
does have me
as signature of borrower and then it has
my grandfather's signature of cosigner
okay so you're looking at the actual
loan agreement
not the lawsuit i'm
looking at the lawsuit they have several
exhibits
okay and one of the exhibits is the
original loan document
correct and it has you as the borrower
as you as the borrower
okay well i'm sorry you're liable
you signed as a borrower how old were
you when you signed that
um six i can't even do that math right
now
uh 23. okay okay you're you're over 18
so you're liable okay i'm not an
attorney but that's the correct answer
all right when you sign a loan document
as the borrower
that means you're liable to pay it does
that make sense
yes so here's what we're gonna do they
say twelve thousand bucks you all have
any money
we can know how much money do you have
do you have any money
save right now i think our savings
account maybe has 1500
in it what can you scrape together
beyond that
um my next big check will be
in november and so i'll have an
additional ten thousand dollars
okay uh
so you have a debt of twelve thousand
dollars that's what they're suing you
for correct
correct okay so i'm and and this is how
many years ago
from 2006 2006
15 years okay so
yeah i would call them and say i don't
have any money
i'm broke i just got served i didn't
even realize i was liable until i read
this exhibit
uh i do have fifteen hundred dollars if
you will accept that
as settlement in full we can settle this
today
they probably won't take that
but you probably can get it for about 25
cents on the dollar
not 10 cents on the dollar so if you
could scrape together another 1500 bucks
you probably can settle this
for about 3 000 bucks if you can get
them to agree to that on the phone
you get that in writing you do not give
them electronic access to your checking
account
and then you wire them the money
directly or you send them a money order
or a prepaid debit card or something
that does not interfere with your
regular
monies but scrape together a couple of
thousand bucks here
two to three thousand dollars i think
you can talk them into taking that
as a settlement in full get it in
writing
before you send it to them and do not
let them into your personal checking
account
as a part of the deal